Will a massive earthquake be triggered by the total solar eclipse
coming up in America on April 8th?
Well, there's a crazy theory going around that it will.
The paths of the 2017 and the 2024 total solar eclipses
forms an X directly over the New Madrid fault line.
The New Madrid fault line is located in the Midwestern United States
and is a major seismic zone for earthquakes.
For instance, in 1811 and 1812,
the New Madrid earthquakes were a series of intense quakes
that remained to be some of the largest earthquakes
ever recorded in North America.
Around that same time,
you had a total solar eclipse in 18:06,
and you also had the annual eclipse of 1811.
The US Geological Survey,
the USGS,
reported that
earthquakes are three times more likely during an eclipse
due to the gravitational forces between the earth,
the moon, and the sun.
Not only that,
but days ago, you had local weather reports
talking about over 16,000 lightning strikes
all along the path that the total eclipse of 2024 is going to take.
So if there is a massive earthquake in the New Madrid fault line,
we're talking about a number of states that will be impacted by this.
Illinois, Missouri,
Arkansas, Kentucky,
Tennessee, and to a lesser extent,
Mississippi and Indiana.
What else is weird
is that Oklahoma has announced
that the National Guard will be deployed
to assist with local law enforcement,
local agencies
to support
the massive influx of people that are coming into these areas.
What's odd about this,
though,
is that you have a report coming out stating that the elite chemical,
biological, radiological and nuclear units will also be dispatched.
So the National Guard is being deployed in Oklahoma
because of the influx of people,
not because of nuclear radiological events.
Right. So why are they dispatching this elite chemical biological team
that deals with this kind of stuff?
It's very strange.
If I had to put money on it,
I bet nothing's gonna happen.
But you never know what's gonna happen,
so always be prepared.